failed former president Donald Trump
gave an interview so bad last night to
Fox News propagandist Sean Hannity so
depraved so visibly disoriented that
even Republicans are saying dude that
was not good we're going to look at the
comments of Republicans in a moment but
let's first look at what happened in the
interview again the interview handled by
Trump's I guess friend at least at one
point friend to the extent Trump has
friends Fox News propaganda Sean Hannity
and Trump spent much of the interview
equivocating about the threat of
violence against Manhattan D.A Alvin
Bragg that he posted a few days ago and
attacking Ron DeSantis neither of which
played particularly well with anybody
here Sean Hannity asks Trump about that
death and destruction post and then the
other one showing him holding a bat next
to Alvin Bragg and Trump kind of plays
dumb but his explanation is also
completely unintelligible so will all
this information that came out in your
favor thank you
you talked about death and destruction
and then you the baseball bat picture
yeah next to Alvin Breg and you did take
that down
and my only question is why open
yourself up to criticism you have to
understand that when the story was put
up I put up a story we didn't see
pictures we put up a story that was very
exculpatory very good story from the
standpoint of what we're talking about
what
and they put up a picture of me and you
know where I was holding the baseball
bat it was at the White House make
America by America because they did a
lot of buy America things so I guess
he's saying because the source photo of
the bat wasn't actually him standing
next to Alvin Bragg it's no big deal and
this is a company that makes baseball
events then they put next to that
picture a picture of Alvin Bragg I
didn't do it they did it the the I guess
the people that do the paper or somebody
put pictures together but I was holding
a baseball someone put pictures together
but in order to promote Maiden it wasn't
on your post the truth no no what they
did is we posted the story but they had
a picture up and they then put a picture
up or the picture was put up that nobody
noticed or saw or that nobody thought
was bad these were two isn't this
Crystal Clear separate pictures I was
promoting made in America you make these
baseball bats instead of sending over to
Japan and China and all other places
where they're made this was a company
good company that makes baseball bats
and other things like that in America
they took that picture from the White
House and they put it up and then they
put a picture of Alvin brega okay so of
course we know nobody has alleged that
Trump was actually next to Alvin Bragg
holding a bat to his head the issue is
Trump
publicized the compilation image of
trump holding a bat next to Alvin Bragg
now in this next clip Trump trump seems
to say well when we published it there
was no picture and later the picture
appeared let me be clear so you did not
post the picture of you with a baseball
bat in the Oval Office next to the
picture with Bragg somebody else I
posted a very positive article yeah and
whatever picture they put up they put up
my people didn't put up the picture I
think the picture maybe was either in
the article or was put in the article
later okay so anyway Trump posted it to
Troth Central and uh he seems very much
confused about how the internet works
Trump then talked about his rally over
the weekend which we covered yesterday
in Waco Texas Trump wildly claims that
there were in reality
sixty thousand people there now there
were thirty five hundred people there
but Trump says 60. well I deal with it
we're dealing with very dishonest people
we're dealing with thugs we're dealing
with people I actually believe that hate
our country right uh last night I had a
rally with tens of thousands of people
right the Press admitted there were okay
so he says tens of tens of thousands 25
or 30 000 people that the Press admitted
there were 25 or 30 and then here's the
Whopper because you can double it at
least in Texas Waco Texas right so the
Press admits there were 25 to 30 000 and
so the real number is double which is
sixty thousand there were 3 500 people
there maybe five thousand that's it and
this is a lie as old as Trump's
political career you just make up
numbers about the number of people at
your events and the truth of course is
like you and I know
that the number of people at an event
doesn't actually tell us much about how
much of the country supports Trump trump
might have had 3 000 or 20 000 people it
happened to be 3 500 but imagine that he
had twenty thousand that still doesn't
mean that he would win an election or
that he won in 2020 or whatever the case
may be but Trump and people around him
see the number of people at one rally as
some kind of proxy to his totality of
support in a country of 340 million
Trump then claimed that he would solve
the Russian invasion of Ukraine in a day
but he definitely can't explain how
because then his enemies would know his
plan World War one and World War II
looked like Patty Cakes okay uh this
unbelievable because we have people that
don't know what they're doing but if
it's not solved I will have it solved in
24 hours with zelinski and with Putin
right and there's a very easy
negotiation to take place but I don't
want to tell you what it is because then
I can't use that negotiation it'll never
work but there's a very easy negotiation
to take place I will have it within one
day right first day in office Trump
would that I mean that's as realistic as
he's going to solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict in the
first term he's going to build the
Mexico wall where Mexico will pay for it
none of it's believable this is as
unbelievable as anything else then we
get to what is for some people the Crux
of this interview
DeSantis and Trump really going after
DeSantis and this is what a lot of
Republicans didn't like starts with
Hannity just asking I thought you guys
were friends and Trump says no we were
never friends
the question I'm asked most about about
you of late is Rhonda Santos right this
is the question
what happened
I thought they were friends
what happened they're not friends I
didn't know him well but he was on
impeachment okay so Trump says and then
they cut uh he says we were not friends
and I didn't really know the guy then we
really get into the meat of it and Trump
again telling the story of when Ron
DeSantis came to Trump with tears in his
eyes and again I continue to be shocked
that the number of grown men sobbing
around Donald Trump something about
Trump makes big tough guys SOB so what
happened with Ron is the following he
came to see me he was getting killed he
was being crushed Adam Putnam it was
over I have many people that I know that
worked for Adam Putnam they said it was
like a new thing I hate to use this
expression it was like a nuclear weapon
went off when you endorsed because they
considered the race to be over they had
the race he had millions and millions of
dollars and he was way up in the polls
he was beating Ron by 30 points or said
it was over
Ron came to see me tears in his eyes he
said I need you to do me a big favor
yeah first he asked for the meeting then
he asked me for the favor crying I said
what's the favor
would you endorse me
I fought for you and but again he a lot
of people fought for me you fought for
me only rightfully but you fought for me
if you thought I was right right a lot
more than he did
but he said I need your endorsement
I said Ron you so far behind I can't
imagine does anyone believe this story
if you've got George Washington's
endorsement combined with the great late
great Abraham Lincoln if you had their
endorsements I don't think you could win
run but
tell me about it go ahead he said I'm
telling you I think I could win if I
could get your endorsement and he was
you'll have to check the records but
many many points it was over and the
nomination just very close the
nomination was just okay
I gave I said let's give it a shot okay
you know you defended me Adam Putnam
didn't one way or the other I think he's
probably a nice guy you know I never met
him until later a year later I met him
he said when you did that it was like a
rocket went up he said my race was over
they were already buying furniture for
the for the Governor's Mansion they were
going to win all right so anyway Trump
saying DeSantis cried to him uh and then
that's uh and the rest is history and
then lastly Trump claiming that DeSantis
would be making pizza if it weren't for
Trump then I had him get him I had to
get him against the star of the Democrat
Party was going to be Stacey Abrams and
they now we call him a crackhead because
that's what he was a crackhead and then
kill him kill him and there was no way
Ron was going to beat Gillum so he got
the nomination but there was no way
because this guy was going to be the
future of the Democrat Party uh and I
said Ron you can beat this guy let's go
I got him the nomination by the way
couldn't have never gotten a nomination
he would be working in either a pizza
parlor place or a law office right now
okay there you go he would be either in
a pizza parlor or a law office which
isn't that bad I mean I think that those
are two very different careers a lot law
office or pizza parlor but needless to
say Trump is responsible
deranged visibly confused and
disoriented Trump but most importantly
more and more Republicans don't like
this